How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world is the trilogy capper to a very
successful series of films so far I've
liked both of the first two films and in
this one hiccup discovers that toothless
is not the only Night Fury they run into
a new dragon they call a light fury
which starts a little bit of a
friendship slash romance between
toothless and this dragon that starts an
investigation to find the hidden world a
world where dragons can feel safe and
comfortable all the while an evil dragon
trapper named grimille is trying to find
them so we can capture these dragons
like I said I really like the first two
dragons films my wife is a fan of the
show on Netflix and so we've experienced
a lot of this in our house and I was
excited to see if they could make a
really good modern trilogy and they did
this is actually a really really good
movie beautifully gorgeously rendered
one of the best things about these films
is the animation but this one in
particular there's one shot early on
where we pan from hiccup and toothless
flying over to this gigantic amount of
dragons that are just filling the screen
and nothing looks copy and paste
everything just looks like it's living
and breathing within the image
the animation here is absolutely
spectacular the relationships are well
preserved as well it all feels like a
natural progression of what we've
already seen there are some surprises
along the way to some things I didn't
expect my wife is a much bigger fan of
this series than I am like she's like I
said she watches the show and so she
went in really afraid about certain
things happening and she was surprised
by what she saw and so was I that this
film has a good way of setting you up
for something but showing you something
that maybe you didn't entirely expect
it's not as good I would say as the
other two though I think this might be
the worst of the three but it's sort of
like a Return of the Jedi case where
like I fucking love Return of the Jedi
but it's not the best this is by no
means a bad film I mean my god it's a
great family movie the music is
spectacular it's really funny the action
sequences are extremely exciting like I
said the animation it's just narrative
ly not as interesting as the other two
and a lot of it comes down to the
villain grimille is a very boring
villain he's just another
dragon trapper there's not much to him
in fact as I was watching the movie I
was almost thinking I could do without a
villain which I know will never happen
but I was so interested in their search
for the hidden world and hiccup and
toothless finding this new Night Fury in
this kind of relationship that was
developing I didn't really care about
grandma I was like he doesn't even have
to be in this movie really I get that
they need a threat they absolutely need
a threat but he was just a really boring
villain the best scene in the movie by
far is toothless trying to woo this
Night Fury and trying to impress her by
doing various things drawing on the sand
dancing around very very funny scene
because it all relies on visual
storytelling there's no dialogue it's
just these two dragons trying to woo
each other really great stuff I think if
you love this series it's going to
please you it's going to give you what
you need in regards to where these
characters end up I really love the
ending I think it's a really great
ending but it's just not as interesting
or as impressive as those first two
still though really damn good movie I'm
gonna give How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden world Abbey guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]